and so i think for the first time in my
life
i am really embracing
not knowing
you know that doesn't mean i'm sitting
there doing nothing you know but i'm
really just embracing like
i don't know but i'm completely like my
prayer now danica is
universe i am open and available to
being
used and of service for the highest good
i'm open to being like use me for the
service the highest good of humanity and
and and it's become less about
okay this is what i want
this is what i want here are my goals
and it's become more about
feeling
what is life what is the divine what is
the universe what is
what is the deepest impulse of what life
is seeking to express through me now
what is the deepest impulse of what life
is seeking to manifest through me now
and doing my best to
attune to that and feel that and and
align
put my personality
with this movement of what life is
seeking to express you know and it's
it's
i have senses i have definite feelings
and so
i think when we surrender
in that way
we transcend ourselves and i think when
we do that we transcend our personal
power we transcend our egos we tap into
another dimension of life another
dimension
of the universe and
like that's when we tap the magic and
life begins to live us more life begins
to move through life begins to manifest
to us more and i think that's when
miracles can kind of happen well
the name of the book is the magic of
surrender so that's when the magic
happens but like this is something that
just came to mind i see things kind of
visually um but it's almost like when we
are who we think we're supposed to be we
can only be that one thing and we're not
that we are not able to
we're only that we walk through life in
a silo that is not as impactful but when
we dissolve the ideas of what we think
we're supposed to be
we now actually become a portal
for
for more people to work through us and
and be affected in a positive way
and we can
we have that sort of like it's almost
like we can create alchemy with people
where when we think we're one thing we
are only that one thing and it's a
narrow existence but when we get rid of
that now we can be everything for
everybody and it's so much bigger
yeah i think
you know in in the surrender like
there's this idea that if we truly
surrender
we're giving up we're
going to be taking advantage of we won't
manifest our goals dreams a limited idea
of what we think we're going to live our
goals dreams and desires but you know
what i'm feeling and seeing in my own
life and what i've what i've seen and
experienced with those around me is when
we surrender
what if we got more
you know like surrender is to really
like take the limits off of life because
from the perspective of the mind and the
personality and the ego
we're only able to see a very limited
perspective
of the tapestry of life and the
possibilities of life and it's like
looking at a painting but we're seeing
the corner of the painting but we don't
see the whole painting itself and and so
many times from the perspective of the
ego and the i like what do i want
uh what we think we want
is just what we think we want based on
who we think we are
and it's limited and so sometimes we get
what we think we want we manifest what
we thought we wanted from the level of
the ego
only to be dissatisfied and and so i
think when we truly take the limits off
of life then we're then we're available
then we're open then we're not holding
on like it has to be this i have to be
that so i think it's part of surrender
is it's like if you surrender what if
you got what if you got more what if you
got more than you could even
imagine for yourself what if you got
more than you could even visualize and
and and
contextualize and write in your journal
like to me life is bigger than us you
know and so things can flow so fast too
like when you get out of the way of your
ideas and you are in alignment
i don't know about you but i i've had so
many experiences where all of a sudden
plans will change to make my life better
in simple ways that i could have never
done like people canceling something so
that i could do this other thing or
things that i could have never arranged
and you're like and they can happen on
this level and they can also happen on
really macro levels that affect your
entire life and your trajectory
um but can you explain the energetics of
that grasping and of that um
uh attachment
and the pat like we're talking about the
power of the surrender but i want to go
into the other side of it to understand
what it feels like when you're not
surrendering
what what's happening why because i mean
i've had experiences again
um where i'll
want something even something kind of
simple like oh just oh i wonder if this
person's gonna call me or something and
then all of a sudden i let go and not
like oh well but like i truly in my
heart i feel it and i'm like they're
probably busy it's not a big deal i'll
hear from them and then all of a sudden
like the it just boom i hear from them
right away i mean that's just a simple
silly example
but this sort of grasping at something
and when you truly let go just can you
explain the energy yeah
i i think the grasping
you know we kind of touched on it but
comes from that egoic sense right and
and the ego
is seeking a perceived sense of self to
keep us safe to avoid pain and so
there's this idea
that we mistakenly have
that if i ego if i can
control my feelings control how you
perceive me if i can control every
thing
then i'm gonna be safe
then i won't get hurt again which is why
we grasp which is why we tend to to
control everything because it's
beautiful in tension but it's it's it's
going to drive us crazy anxiety
frustration fear and so in that grasping
is tightness in that grasping this
contraction is like in that grasping is
imagine you just go through life holding
your breath you know and you're
spiritually constipated so to speak and
you're just holding on it's like
life can't flow
energy can't flow the universe can't
flow and so blessings might come through
energetically but this you know they're
kind of like a stone they would just
bounce off of you versus just
being open and so i think when we let go
of that grasping
and we're available
and we're open
to me part of success
is not just about hard work with a
closed fist but it's about openness and
availability because when we're open and
available
energy floats energy circulates life is
able to flow then we're also in a much
more
available state
a receptive energetic state to receive
you know when we're grasping and holding
on we'll come from the standpoint of
force not flow and when we're in force
it's like we're trying to make something
happen that may not be
what it's meant to be and trying to make
something into something that it's not
doesn't make it so and so when we're
holding on
and gripping tightly
trying to make something into something
but life might be trying to take us in a
different direction and so when we're
holding on so tightly sometimes we end
up
missing the flow of where life is going
because we're so busy holding on to that
rock when the river's already going that
way so so part of surrender is taking
the limits off part of surrender was
allowing part of surrender availability
part of surrender was the openness to
say okay
to allow i think when we let go of that
grasping of who we think we should be
often based on our conditioning and the
way we think our life should be
based on our conditioning and many of
our goals are sometimes
projections of unmet needs from our
childhood you know and so when we let go
of that graspy totally
then we're like
then we can allow them the energy of
life
that is authentically moving then we can
allow the authentic movement of life of
what a life is seeking to be that
intelligence that's inside that nose
then then we can allow what life is
authentically seeking to reveal to
unfold
and there
an innate intelligence side of us
it's inside of us already there's that
that that is
what it is
let's just talk biologically for a
second let's not even be spiritual just
cut your finger
yeah
something i don't whatever you want to
call it that innate intelligence
it knows how to heal yeah you and i we
we don't have to sit here oh cut my
finger [ __ ] down i could cut my finger i
got to pray about it gotta do some
special mantra gotta do some
visualization i have to be a good person
you could be pablo escobar el chapo it
doesn't matter you don't have to be
mother teresa just cut your finger the
innate intelligence life knows how to
heal
and so i think
we're kind of disconnected from that you
know we've forgotten that we've gotten
so busy distracted condition that we've
lost touch with
this innate intelligence that's inside
of us and we've begun to override it so
i think if we can just even
bring ourselves back into relationship
to the body
and just just simply
maybe just start by feeling the breath
like
sounds simple basic but
what is that like we're having this
conversation
and you're you and i we're not sitting
here all those listening we're not
sitting here going
i have to breathe i
in spite of us
there's an effortlessness
to the breath
that is happening
you know you ate this morning or this
afternoon lunch breakfast and
something is digesting your food
and there is an intelligence this innate
intelligence there are trillions and
trillions and trillions and trillions
and trillions of cells in your body
that are interacting and synchronizing
and coordinating and mitochondria and
eyes and liver and
it's all just it's all
happening
in spite of us
you
know and
we don't trust life we don't trust that
that that thing that is like there's a
thing whatever god define it i don't
think energy whatever label you want to
call it energy
there's an energy
that is functioning you me
eight billion people
the cockroaches the tigers the giraffes
the birds all of existence that you know
it's just
it's happening
without you and i it's just unfolding
the sun and the stars so i think if we
can just
kind of be still and bring ourselves
into relationship with
the breath and just go
just like sit with that like
what is breathing right now you know
just even just meditating because when
we do when i know what i do
it's mind blowing what the hell is that
like something is
is is
it's alive and to me that innate
intelligence is
the rhythm of life you know that innate
intelligence is unfolding life my father
was a really great he is a great man
would say to me when i was a kid when i
would stress and worry a lot as a child
he would say to me
son why why are you worrying so much
about everything you want about all
these things all these things why are
you worrying so much he would say did
you bring yourself here
where did you bring yourself to this
planet did you bring yourself
to this existence and i would say well
no i just showed up here and he said
exactly
so
do you not think that whatever it is
that brought you here
that it this intelligence
does it not know how to unfold you did
the trees struggle did the the fruit
struggle did the the does the grass
struggle to gross like did they no so
why do you stress and so i think we
kind of trust
like i was joking to someone the other
day like we trust siri more than we
trust this intelligence you know and
and yet
if we just if we just observe ourselves
and we just observe the nature of life
like this i'm looking at trees and i'm
looking at the sky i'm looking at the
sun it's like holy [ __ ] like it's
amazing